let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 we will start with our caller from
the 501 area code caller from 501
introduce yourself go ahead hey David
it's Anthony again hey doing a second
saw good I just wanted to know what your
thoughts on Kavanaugh inevitable
and and wasn't that just horrible or
rally rant the other day I'm drunk yeah
so you're thinking what my thoughts are
about what's going to happen with
Kavanaugh I was asking you oh no Trump's
rally but um rally rant the other day
but um no I was asking about that I
don't think it's inevitable I actually
don't think Kavanaugh is inevitable I
think that there is the possibility here
that if just I mean listen we know that
there are Republican senators who are
thinking of voting now and that's all
it's going to take to torpedo Kavanaugh
I do think it's inevitable that Trump is
going to get a conservative justice on
the court and I think that those on the
Left who are saying well you know if we
can push it out enough to the midterms
and then at that point if Democrats take
it over then they can just block any
nominee and then put Merrick garland
back up that would be lovely
I just don't think it's going to happen
so I think what is inevitable is Trump
getting a pick totally all right thanks
man all right thanks Anthony appreciate
the call